المكان اصبح صحيح اصبح مزار للناس وبيروح
وبيجوا بيجوا بغيره جاء اجواء اجواء يعني
ما تاخذنيش الاجواء اللي في المدينه
[موسيقى]
كان هدوء انا في اشجار في ورد في شجر في
48 في يعني الهواء نقي يعني تستنشق هوائقي
مش انا غبره وضو المكان هذا مريح جدا
[موسيقى]
طبعا انت لما بدك تروح على البحر انك انت
بيكون حواليك كتير في ناس وانت ما بتقدرش
انك انت تاخد راحتك فيه يعني بتيجي
هالساعتين بتشوف البحر بتلبس الاولاد
وبتخلص اما في الاماكن اللي زي هيك انت
ممكن تقعد نهار كامل وبامكانك كمان انك
تبات وكل شيء موفر لالك
[موسيقى]
انك بتلتم الستورات الفلسطيني في هذا
الموضوع انه انت عملك بتشتغل على شغل
تراثي بحث اكلات تراثيه بحته فعلا احنا
بنحتاج انه يكون في عنا كتير من الاماكن
اللي زي هيك في قطاع غزه
[موسيقى]
بشوف ابن نسيم انه هي فعلا بتاكد على قوه
المراه وثبات المراه وحضور المراه وفي كل
المجالات وبالذات في اماكن زي كذا منطقه
خطيره او منطقه قريبه جدا من الشريط
الحدودي انه ام نسيم تعمل هيك
قاعده او هيك يعني مكان عن جد كثير رائع